[Music]
Eldon ring is a story with a central
Throne of power and it is famously
co-created by George R.R Martin so we
could call it another Game of Thrones
but I think a better subtitle would be a
game of death since dying is everywhere
in the lands between even more so than
in Westeros you die a lot as the player
the boss's dialogue the normal enemies
die a lot and then they respond and die
a lot again essentially every step of
progression in the game comes from
killing something and death is pretty
Central to the lore as well half of the
monsters and Cults in the lands between
seem to focus on death and the inciting
moment for the whole game is Godwin
dying during the night of the Black
Knights plus one of the most intriguing
lore characters is mikola someone who is
cursed with eternal youth a thematic
opposite to death and in another
juxtaposition to Godwin being Forever
Young with silky smooth skin also seems
like the opposite side of the coin of
death and being a giant rotting fish
corpse though moog's blood cocoon does
kind of Ruin any of those impossibly
wrinkle-free porcelain skin benefits
with death being such an omnipresent
aspect of the game it's a good place to
look as we speculate on potential DLC a
review may prepare us for the new
content especially if that content ends
up focusing on mikola and or Godwin two
of the seemingly likeliest candidates so
let's dive into how death presents
throughout the game feel free to
subscribe if you haven't especially if
you watch my videos anyway as it helps
out the channel an Elden ring death is
an inciting moment a measure of progress
and a focal point for most of the game's
inhabitants the events of the game all
started with a rebellion against
America's ceiling of death at the dawn
of the golden order death was partially
reintroduced during the night of the
black knives and the killing of her son
Godwin that was the Catalyst for the
shattering a massive war of battles and
death which eventually brought the
tarnished back to the lands between and
set us on our journey and even that
Journey we take through the game begins
with death to either the grafted Scion
or a butterfly bait maybe America would
have had a better time if she sealed the
other half of Ben Franklin's Fort since
an eternal life where you never get to
die in your Forever taxed by Royals
likely doesn't make for a happy Kingdom
throughout our journey we come across a
host of enemies bosses and sex obsessed
with death the bosses we come across
must almost uniformly be killed for us
to progress through the game and same
with all the Lesser enemies that dot the
land though unlike the bosses these
lesser combatants infinitely respond so
their deaths are less permanent they're
suffering more drawn out and we've
already seen the Cults of death on the
channel before our looked at the Raven
Mountain assassin and the Fallen Hawks
led us to discuss the ghost flame and
the death rate Birds we read from the
explosive ghost flame spell that in a
time when there was no herb tree death
was burned in ghost blame death birds
were the keepers of that fire the
deathbirds maintain a rate of death that
predates the Earth tree and they house
the deathrite priests within their wings
the death ritual spear tells us that the
priest became Guardians of the birds
Through The Rite of death which also
serves as an oath sworn to their distant
Resurrection one day they may fully
surpass death and be resurrected but
that may require an end to the Earth
tree's dominance and a return to the
right of death allowing the death Birds
to continue their old right unobstructed
we found the Raven Mountain assassin
mimicking these birds of death picking
on some of their power cosplaying as the
Macabre wings and aligning with Moog the
Assassin invades tarnish to kill and
Slaughter may be hoping to bring back
the right of his favorite Birds but we
don't see the deathrite come back in
this way since we put an end to Raven
Mount by helping Yuri Turn The Invasion
tables continuing our journey away from
real birds we saw the band of the Fallen
Hawks who came about the ghost plane
underground they burned the bones of
their dead comrades having run out of
supplies to burn for light their own
existence as slaves sentenced to search
the underground Rivers may have been a
result of Overworld War campaigns and
the ones that didn't die during the wars
or the search were cursed with undeath
after they found the ghost flame they
sealed their fate as dwellers of the
underground for all eternity death
likely would be a welcome reprieve for
the Hawks but it only comes momentarily
by us tarnished and only until we once
again rest at a Grace
another Denizen of the underground we
found were the Wisps unnamed but deadly
balls of lightning and Magic it was hard
to draw any conclusions about these
creatures but it did seem likely to me
that they had connections to the
ancestrals and their unique cycle of
life and death we read from the
remembrance of the Regal ancestor that
ancestral Spirits exist as a phenomenon
beyond the purview of the erdry life
spreads from Death as it does from birth
such as the way of the living here is
another case of a system of death that
is independent from the earth tree
despite how Central the tree seems to
the lands between older forms of living
and dying keep popping up Traditions
that the golden order has been unable to
Stamp Out despite all the surprisingly
not infrequent genocide and speaking of
the golden order it only exists because
America can find destined death by
sealing the old form of death which
could have connections to the deathrite
birds we previously talked about the
golden order set up the Earth trees
Reign a rain which handled life and
death differently than those who came
before it some examples we see are the
Earth tree burials of great Heroes and
the remembrances of the powerful being
sown into the Earth tree itself we also
have the ghosts throughout the game Who
mention the process one in the stormfoot
catacombs says a proper death means
returning to the Earth tree have
patience until the time comes and The
Roots call to you there's a whole
conversation we could get into about how
the greater will may have changed life
and the character of death in the lands
between speaking through Irena the
frenzy flame blames the greater will for
individuated life and a departure from
the primordial one great its ending
seeks an end to life and death by
returning to a big ball of fire or human
instrumentality or something like that
this could segue into a discussion of
the earth tree The Crucible and the
discussion muddying great tree but I'll
leave that larger talk for another video
one thing I will say is that the
mentioned roots of both the herd tree
and the gray tree bring us to what is
likely the largest focal point of death
in the game the first slain demigod God
Godwin the golden
Godwin resides as the strongest symbol
of death imaginable a corpse his soul
has been killed but his body remains
bearing only half of the curse mark of
death his soulless body spreads death
root throughout the lands between death
root that is eaten by the alter ego of
malachyth the one who holds destined
death sealed and Beyond The Roots
Godwin's face spreads through the lands
as well appearing on creatures like
corrupted Crustaceans and of course
there are those who live in death who
could view the death Prince as their
lord we see that the deathbed companion
Thea certainly does and through her
allegiance to him wishes to become
mother to those who live in death
through fear the corpse of Godwin is the
centerpiece for the ending of the game
which reintroduces death back into the
lands between it is also the seat of
death which turned fortisex into an
undead Lich Dragon any discussion of
death and Elder ring from a story
perspective will have to end up
revolving around Godwin his character as
the first Dead demigod mixed with his
large Larger than Life Fish corpse is
something that just can't be ignored
this plus the fact that his early death
prevented us as players from Ever
Getting to see Godwin moseying around
like a normal person makes him a solid
candidate for some kind of appearance in
the DLC there's just so much room to
explore and while I think a gallon
feature is likely in some way we should
remember that there are other demigods
surrounded by death too up in Mount
gilmir there is the cycle of death that
Prater reichardt perpetuates in his
serpent cult Riker rejected the Earth
tree gaining the ire of morga he turned
to the old religion and secret powers
found around what is now volcano Manor
he became one with the god devouring
serpent his remembrance telling of how
he took the form of a giant serpent that
he might devour grow and live eternally
he eats those around him to grow in
power and when we defeat him we see
tanith trying to do the same this
cannibalism on display is truly a cycle
of blasphemy against the golden order a
seeking of death and life on terms away
and outside of what the Earth tree has
in mind
reichard's brother is surrounded by
death too but this one is or was much
more in line with the machinations of
gold and the greater Wilt the great
General radon was one who sought honor
and Glory through following in the
footsteps of the golden orders greatest
Champions his father radagon and his
Idol Godfrey we come across him mindless
and unwittingly like his brother
slopping up the remains of the Dead on
the battlefield though radon does not
have a cult of enablers his old General
Jaron hosts the Festival of Rodan with
the goal of finally giving the warrior
demigod a proper send-off a death in
glorious combat and we tarnished meet
this challenge riding into battle with a
host of Warriors who may die and return
to battle endlessly radon as a paragon
of war is surrounded by death and our
meeting with him is just one more
vanquishing of the Mortal coil and after
talking about radon there is another
combat crazy demigod that must be
brought up my personal pronunciation
challenge Melania she may not be as
death Centric in lore but is a beacon of
dying nonetheless Melania is The Game's
icon of death her rot lore does bear a
connection to death with the contrast of
stagnation and rot as compared to the
renewing and change of life and death
and her gameplay stands on its own in
delivering the game's emphasis on death
and overcoming we get another picture of
contrast when we look at her brother the
mysterious demigod Nikola he is cursed
with eternal youth a kind of rot or
stagnation of his own kind as he stands
in stasis against death never getting
closer to Life's Natural end
juxtaposition jumps out again between
the Ageless or may we say deathless
Eternal youth of mikola and the first
death and rotting of Godwin nikola's
youth is obviously messed up to some
degree by Moog another demigod with
strong connections to death through his
connection to the formless mother blood
sacrifices and invading his Entourage
also has a thing for dead maidens so
mikola's current relationship to death
is hard to say for CERN but it likely
presents a great opportunity for DLC
overall plenty about mikula is unknown
so there's a lot of artistic room for
fromsoft to meander about it plus what
we do know about Nikola sets the stage
thematically well he tried to fight
against the influence of the outer gods
and the curse of rot upon his sister he
tried to create a new urge tree and help
Godwin die a proper death the golden
epithet likely captures the words of the
young demigod when it quotes oh brother
Lord Brother please die a true death
mikola was prepared for death and
rebirth and seemed to favor that over a
stagnation and beyond that between
Castle Soul the eclipse the Headless
soldiers and the Halle tree there are
quite a few branches of connection
between the first Dead demigod and his
eternally youthful brother two opposites
with so much linking them together
nikola's dream as the dlc's setting is
an idea that has been passed around a
lot in the community and it does provide
a good opportunity for expression
fromsoft could basically do whatever
they want whether that's show a
non-catatonic mikola a Godwin in his
prime or anything else we didn't get to
see in the base game so it may have
Merit and the pervasiveness of death
might drive home its plausibility we've
seen that death pops up everywhere in
this game and there are plenty more
references that I still haven't touched
on there is the dung eater who seeks to
curse the Earth tree cycle of rebirths
there are the walking mausoleums and
their headless Knights the Frozen
mountain tops of the Giants are littered
with corpses the entire biome is a
cemetery and there are even more minor
and obscure characters like roses and
Realms like the Halpin there is more
death to explore here but for this video
and touching on the DLC I think just
their mention does enough to really
drive home the omnipresence of death in
the game
with all of that it makes sense that a
DLC would continue the deathly Trend
mikula and Godwin are both prominent
explorable figures with Keen connections
to death and I would really hope and
even expect to see at least one of them
if not both featured I am making a video
all about how I think the idea has Merit
after all Elden ring like its spiritual
predecessors is a game of death death is
the measure of our persistence to stick
with the game and overcome the
challenges it presents us it is how from
soft crafts and delivers the experience
they intend I talked about this
utilization of death a lot in my
philosophy of Elden ring video so check
that out if you want more on the topic
death is basically the game's central
theme I'm sure it will feature
prominently in the DLC obviously through
the gameplay we can expect to die plenty
as is tradition and it will almost
assuredly come through the story and
lore as well we don't know what that
story content will be for sure though
maybe we'll find out soon after this
video comes out the game's one-year
anniversary is coming up pretty soon I'm
betting that the the death themes of
Nikola and Godwin will feature in some
way but fromsoft could always throw us a
curveball so what do you think the DLC
will feature story-wise let me know in
the comments and feel free to subscribe
to the channel if you haven't already
enjoy the video or support the channel
on patreon thanks for watching the video
I'll see you in the next one bye